artists getting like their chains
snatched like how do i get my chain back
like it happened that happened to tiger
right yeah um it happened to a lot of
people
being getting your change stats back
then was crazy like your career that was
like
yeah
it was pretty much was done i mean dude
that [ __ ] haunted
young berg for a while it pretty much
was for real [ __ ] like and here i did
get this chain snatch twice like when i
came around
like people was like really trying to
[ __ ] with them and bully them and do all
this [ __ ] because when you not from a
gang that's what gangs really do to you
too especially when you hot you're
popular
got songs out you on tv [ __ ] see you in
the street they want to take advantage
of you all right and that [ __ ] just
wasn't flying with me so he already had
the coconut juice [ __ ] then [ __ ] was
already still trying to [ __ ] with him
and and bullying and doing all that but
when i came around i'm like damn they
doing all of this [ __ ] to you i'm like
all right get on youtube i'm like let me
give me the list to everybody that's
that's dissing you and [ __ ] with you
right now all right cool say no more
i'll be right back
like probably like a couple weeks [ __ ]
i spoke to everybody except one [ __ ]
you feel me i'm like hey that's out
[ __ ] we ain't doing that no more often
what was it like it was like rap beef
that you squashed yeah just like little
rat beef and like little homies but it
was a couple [ __ ] that's really from
gangs you know i'm saying that was doing
a thing who's like the the most notable
beef you squashed for tyga in that era
probably the the young homie named
gutter he was for bounty hunters i mean
he was my homie too like he was my room
like hey come to my house for me i'm
like hey i'm kicking it with the young
[ __ ] man lika along you know what i'm
saying we ain't gonna do that no more
because i ain't trying to [ __ ] up my
little reputation and all that my homies
call me a [ __ ]
so we ain't gonna do that [ __ ] no more